c'est quand même dingue
j'ai regardé fleurs sont trop belles
adresses françaises
apprenti de fleurs ah oui et non
[Musique]
hashtags amar chaoui située à voir c'est
super en fait leur spécialité c'est de
faire des descendants qui a fait quoi la
terre de leurs sages et c'est pour ça
que tu mènes le cappuccino le grande
famille photo tu avais pris le footing
en toi ces centres ont dit non tu vas
pas posté cette photo c'est pas ton café
bas mais non bah oui alors faute toof
c'est trop beau sort il faut j'utilise
chez rita photos et les troubles et
senna farine d'années m tu as bien
s'achever sous peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore bas possible sa cinquième qui est
toutefois c'est nul ton truc moi je ne
comprends pas d'accord les fissures
instinct quand elles le font elles ça
marche c'est toi qui as puma loisirs
fait une dernière fois ça va encore
[ __ ] mais c'est nu son truc
iam est ce qu'il est mignon je
l'appelais sweety sweety mettait pas
allergique aux chiens toi moi non jeu de
mémoire non alice tu as pris un chiot
pour avoir plus de l'aïe sur un star
mais pas du tout est folle ou quoi va
s'y prendre deux secondes faut que je
prenne mes hôtes histaminique caméra tu
prend pas en photo mais like mon chiot
jeu
sweety 1 on était quand même très
allergique un enfer non non non non en
fait non heureusement que ça fait des
like
et le chouchou vas-y prend la photo non
mais c'est pas mon téléphone tu m'as dit
que tu prenais lithium et non pas du
tout aimé notre charge
ça tire ça tire son niveau en même temps
ok on sait france gt concept voilà
hockey ayew à gauche s'interroge thomas
kausch et les mêmes ont choqué les
petits pas petit pas quelques au nord je
suis désolé mon cher
le plant pas le type en parlent le plus
humide et le teaser puisqu'il privées
toutes les photos seront poste avant la
pause tu as laissé une photo quand même
qu'après supprimés ah bon vas-y supprime
là je suis avec toi
non mais c'est peut être une erreur je
paie sa vie tout se met enfin c'est
ridicule je suis la supprimer c'est
peut-être une crise ou pas la supprimer
parce que c'est celle qu'elle plus de
l'oeil sur ton instinct
[Musique]
j'ai pu et bien supprime là elle est là
oui ça fait mal
oui oui mon chemin non non je les rangs
du non ça faisait pas assez dingue mais
n'importe quoi tout en béton mais non
c'est parce que je suis allergique tu
vois bien on va où là à une animalerie
je prends un chat mais a laissé aussi
allergique aux chiens laissera percer
sur la star apparaît bien maintenue dire
bah si
ton petit crop en lien avec ta petite
veste sur ma story quand j'ai demandé
est-ce que vous validez ma tenue du jour
a répondu non
on peut savoir qui a voté sur instagram
sur les statistiques de plus vers le
haut ah bon ah mais en fait ça va me
permettre de savoir qui a voté boit pas
mon maquillage du jour j'ai mis un temps
[Musique]
et voilà comment on fait une très belle
couronne britannique allons nous
regrouper les coudes et on arrive à
calais pourquoi maintenant c'est un
courant de fluence et d'arts plastiques
mais ces papillons attendu attaques ont
pris la tangente de merde salpêtre à
bientôt sur un prochain à temps les plus
magnifiques venus aux poings salfit
[Musique]
oui c'est encore un placement de produit
non non c'est annulé c'est pas si bien
payé 1
j'ai un code promo si vous voulez
maintenant mais les passeports
là non plus bas voilà voilà maintenant
pendant quatre jours on pose des photos
de plage qu'on trouve sur internet les
gens seront passe pas de jour on va aux
seychelles
génial bon allez vas-y bien on sort et
ne pas sortir ces gens nous
reconnaissent ça qu'on appelle là-bas
personne n'a jamais reconnu et bah ça
peut arriver on sort pas pendant quatre
jours ouais plus cela comme ça voilà ça
fait une super belle photo ils ont été
pillés ils sont là tous les vols non
[Musique]